YouTube cut some ties with Logan Paul
following the controversy plus the
latest on expecting Kim Khloe and Kylie
where you been hiding Kylie
now the fallout for Logan Paul continues
you guys will remember Logan posted a
video last month which featured images
of an apparent suicide victim at the
time Logan claimed he posted the graphic
footage to raise awareness for suicide
prevention but apparently his - public
apologies wasn't enough YouTube is
distancing themselves from the 22 year
old social media star and they tell et
Logan's channel has been removed from
Google preferred and they are putting a
hold on Logan's original projects that
includes the thinny sequel new world
order I'm excited for the release of the
sequel because I don't know if you know
this when I did the original thinning I
was not doing YouTube I wasn't a YouTube
star just like an Instagram guy a
Facebook guy now your boys that YouTube
saw and the biggest YouTube stock so I
think the success of this one's gonna be
huge now some folks are coming to
Logan's defense including dr. Phil who
explained to ET why he deserves
forgiveness it is a big difference Logan
Paul's only 22 so he posts this video
apparently of an actual body of someone
who had committed suicide in Japan and
he first wrote an apology then gave an
apology video but people are still
calling for him to be removed from
YouTube what do you think he should do
from here
well first off let me say I thought that
what went up on the video and what was
shown was tasteless it was atrocious it
was something that just should not have
been done but let's call timeout here
this is a 22 year old young man and this
is one thing one time one bad decision
let's not judge this young man's whole
life his whole body of work everything
that he's done over one bad decision
it was a terrible decision it was a
terrible thing to put on the internet
kids see that it's it's inexcusable to
do that but that doesn't mean he's a
horrible person I know there are a lot
of Logan Paul stands out there so I want
to know what do you guys think did you
two make the right decision by cutting
ties from Logan what do you think he
should do from here all right we are
going to do a hard pivot and turn to
some kardashian-jenner news because if
you've been like me then you've been
wondering where in the world is Kylie
Jenner Kylie of course is gearing up to
welcome her first kid this year though
no one in the family has yet to confirm
it still the source tells ET the 20 year
old is enjoying her time away from the
spotlight and that she is not only busy
focusing on her pregnancy but also
planning her next professional steps to
quote Kylie's worked hard her entire
life in being a mother will be a lot of
work so now is a chance for her to
recharge as for the other pregnant
Kardashian miss Khloe a source tells ET
she is focused on maintain a healthy
pregnancy I know it sounds obvious but
they say Khloe's priorities are working
out heat and clean and promoting her
show revenge but also in the works
though a possible trade deal for Khloe's
beau Cleveland Cavaliers star Tristan
Thompson the source says that Tristan
may move to Los Angeles and play for the
Clippers but regardless we'll be 100%
hands-on when the baby arrives meanwhile
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West are
expecting their third baby any day now a
source confirms two et that while the
couple surrogate has not yet given birth
that baby girl of theirs is gonna pop
out any day now and Kim and Kanye are
fully prepared to bring her home but
don't expect to see the birth of the
baby on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
the source says Kimye will be in the
delivery room without TV cameras my
friends et has also learned that Kim and
Kanye have not chosen a name for their
second daughter yet but here's what Kim
told us about growing her family and
what north and Saint think about getting
another sibling they are excited I mean
I don't know if they don't feel it as
much because I don't they don't see my
big belly and probably hear me
complaining every two seconds
though but we do talk about it a lot so
they will I think they're really excited
I think my son I don't know how he's
gonna react because he doesn't get it
yet but my daughter's really excited
there is a baby boom of Kardashian's and
can you handle it I know I'm gonna try
to keep up so stick with the daily Deni
and if I don't have any updates for you
I'll just keep doing dumb videos like
the one yesterday if you guys missed it
be sure to check out all the times Kanye
totally upgraded Kim's style and let me
tell you that man is very hands-on all
right I'm out and be sure to like and
share this video and I'll be back
tomorrow with some new music Friday
chance for you all right bye